quoi scoop - ben vrai pas les coupes à
la compagnie scopitone vivait c'est quoi
sourire magnifique
sans déconner ça a eu de la peine parce
que tu es un jingle ans parce que j'ai
un scoop tu verras sata est vrai un jour
mon choix
j'attends de voir et d'entendre le sco
base et vas-y matin j'écoutais france
culture en voiture comme tous les matins
ça mathieu france qu'une meilleure à
studen mon ami guillaume erner qui est
docteur en biologie à votre ami google
il est exceptionnel et qu'il a fait une
chronique il est aussi producteur des
matins de france et donc il a fait une
chronique ce matin en disant que cyril
hanouna non à nous effectivement et bien
de bien entrer au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco est ce que vous savez pourquoi
je promets que c'est vrai c'est pas une
blague grasset dès ce matin sur france
culture est il là d'où ce matin pourquoi
parceque vous aider parce que vous aidez
la la la religion pas là c'est là c'est
la recherche dans merde à préserver
voilà la culture sépharade voilà les
coutures il connaît même pas son scoop
même si je te connais le départ des
régimes orientaux sa part notamment en
introduisant des mots comme d'art car
elle
il a entendu à la radio car vous l'avez
écouté vous non mais écoutez par bull a
pu écouter la raison c'est intéressant
parce que le langage est le fondement de
la culture
alors on a forcément la parole rap la
parole la parole verlan la parole rasta
et oui effectivement vous avez introduit
dans la parole des jeunes la parole race
raache cool et c'est aujourd'hui je
pense que ça sera peut-être bientôt dans
dictionnaire ah ouais ouais bah ils
arrivent à le lire à 14 ans mais ça m'a
touché sa générosité m'a touché c'est
bien oui mais comme attachés en voiture
j'écoute hadji merde voilà s'il a écouté
sans voiture franchement j'étais le
maire arrêtez de nous prendre pour 10 et
pour des gens mérité